>>> "STAR TREK'S" CAPTAIN KIRK
WILL SOON GO TO SPACE FOR REAL
IF YOU DOUBT THAT THE "STAR
TREK" SERIES DID NOT PRESENT A
FACTUAL VIEW OF REALITY.
JEFF BEZOS' SPACE COMPANY BLUE
ORIGIN HAS JUST ANNOUNCED THAT
WILLIAM SHATNER WILL FLY ON
BOARD ITS CRUDE ROCKET ON
OCTOBER 12th.
>> AND 90 YEARS OLD, SHATNER
WILL BE THE OLDEST PERSON TO
EVER GO INTO SPACE.
CNN NOW WITH MORE ON THE
DETAILS.
ABOUT A 15-MINUTE FLIGHT AS I
UNDERSTAND IT.
STILL COUNTS, THOUGH.
>> Reporter: IT STILL COUNTS.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE GOING ABOVE
THE CARMEN LINE, THE
INTERNATIONAL RECOGNIZED
BOUNDARY OF SPACE.
SO THEY'LL GET ABOUT 11 MINUTES
FROM LAUNCH TO LANDING.
ONLY ABOUT THREE OR FOUR MINUTES
OF WEIGHTLESSNESS.
THIS IS GOING TO BE VERY SIMILAR
TO WHAT FOUNDER JEFF BEZOS
EXPERIENCED ON HIS FLIGHT BACK
IN JULY.
BUT REMEMBER, SHATNER IS THE GUY
WHO FAMOUSLY SAID "BEAM ME UP,
SCOTTY."
NOW INSTEAD OF SCOTTY BEAMING
HIM UP TO SPACE IT'S GOING TO BE
THE TEAM AT BLUE ORIGIN.
SO ALSO ON BOARD THIS FLIGHT.
IT'S GOING TO BE LIFTING OFF IN
ALMOST A WEEK, OCTOBER 12th IS
THE TARGET DATE.
ALSO ON BOARD IS AN EMPLOYEE FOR
BLUE ORIGIN.
A FORMER NASA ENGINEER AND
CO-FOUNDER OF PLANET LABS, AND
THE CO-FOUNDER OF A LIFE
SCIENCES COMPANY.
SO FOUR PEOPLE ON BOARD THIS
FLIGHT.
AND THIS IS AN EXCITING TIME FOR
BLUE ORIGIN AFTER NEARLY 20
YEARS OF EXISTENCE.
THEY'RE NOW ON THE CUSP OF THEIR
SECOND CRUDE FLIGHT.
BUT IT'S ALSO A TIME OF RENEWED
SCRUTINY ON THE COMPANY BECAUSE
JUST LAST WEEK A GROUP OF 21
CURRENT AND FORMER EMPLOYEES
CO-SIGNED AN ESSAY DETAILING
WHAT THEY DESCRIBE AS A TOXIC
WORKPLACE ENVIRONMENT.
THEY SAY IT'S A PLACE WHERE
PROFESSIONAL DISSENT IS ACTIVELY
STIFLED.
THEY ALSO TALKED ABOUT CERTAIN
MALE LEADERS ROUTINELY ENGAGING
IN SEXIST BEHAVIOR.
THESE ARE ALL CLAIMS THAT BLUE
ORIGIN ADAMANTLY DENIES.
THEY SAY THAT THEY HAVE NO
TOLERANCE FOR DISCRIMINATION OR
HARASSMENT OF ANY KIND, BUT THEY
ALSO SAY THAT THEY ARE
INVESTIGATING ANY NEW CLAIMS OF
MISCONDUCT.
YOU ALSO HAVE THE FAA REVIEWING
THESE ALLEGATIONS.
NOT AN INVESTIGATION, JUST A
REVIEW.
BUT JIM AND ERICA, 17 SUCCESSFUL
CONSECUTIVE TEST FLIGHTS FOR
THIS NEW SHEPHERD SPACECRAFT.
WILLIAM SHATNER, O